so what's the most extravagant
submission that the Holly shorts Film
Festival has ever received and did it
work like we heard one gentleman
submitted to a festival and he sent like
a hipster gift package which was like
pabst blue ribbon beer and some popcorn
different things like that they said
very nice thank you yeah we've gotten
yeah that's been dead you know we've got
some extravagant submissions but nothing
like that so I kind of disappointed with
nine years going out we haven't got
anything that I figured we get something
even crazier at this point we kind of
have it that's a mouth now thinking
about it like it's a little surprising
how disappointing I wouldn't mind some
random beer coming that'd be kind of
kinda nice but a hook you know I gotta
take a second here I mean there's been
some mo mainly elaborate press kits the
press gets like you know sometimes
people send some really expensive press
kits and now they're within digital we
want that stuff online you know we don't
we don't want that said we don't paper
wasted we don't nothing will consider it
i mean you receive it we're going to
take a look at it but we're not really
going to give it a full pass when it's
not because we're looking at we want the
stuff electronically sign if you're
sending press kit in prescott
information articles on your online
submission or just email to Alyssa PDF
and one that stuff online now you know
just that bulk mail and getting all that
stuff it just uh with all the materials
we get in DVDs and whatnot it's just
it's just a it's a lot and it's
essentially to be honest a waste of
space and you know we've gotten some
it's mainly when it comes to like the
press gets we're like they're just a
full color copies and just like this
huge book of just all types of
information every single player involved
and and you know that kind of stuff and
you know that someone submission where
they give us like they had a they gave
us like like still photographs of every
like cats remembering like full makeup
and full outfit and costume and and it
was like all that kind of stuff and it
was like you know fridge magnet and
dollars that they just they just gave
all there was there was all this stuff
it was like to remember some more stuff
they gave us I don't remember was a
piece of the clothes like the cost of
like it was like all this is just like a
huge press kit and the funny thing is it
was it with its trailer so it was
actually wasn't even it was a trailer
submission which we
trailers missions and we reload the
screen trailers but the press getting
all that stuff was for a 30 second
trailer so it's pretty interesting was
like it's a trailer but the giving this
really allowed and takes so much time to
look through all this stuff but the you
know the film itself the film the
submission is you know it's not even you
know it's long so it's kind of funny
that all things I have this huge nail
press get big package and you know all
this stuff and printed out copies of
this and then photographs of every
single you know I was like this huge
cast and all this stuff and it was for
something so short you felt like that
was that was a house pretty elaborate we
have had some some handwritten letters
you know please of sort to come in you
know stuff like that where it's kind of
why we should like the film and in
handwritten you know which is
interesting i was on rights who writes
hand writing letters and you know the
Dear John letters aren't coming around
anymore we have people to write you
letters like that anymore at hand like
cursive and so they had some letters you
know written about why we just liked the
film and important it was and and and I
guess I gotta be honest I mean some of
those those submissions have generally
been to be frank pretty pretty poor you
know look yeah I mean if they come in
with something that's with that kind of
how is I'm hi Charlie or that's right
but I mean you're saying a letter in
hand written not in some sense not
professional but also just like with a
plea you got assume the film's probably
not going to be good and they haven't
been in that sense when that happens
could have a few time they're not
they're just not you know you know the
film speak for itself and you don't have
to send it and written note that way I
mean I mean in the sense of like on
paper handwritten curse it like a long
letter not like hey thanks for looking
at my suit you know that i'm talking
about that like that's nice and people
do that it's cool little you know the
business card right no thank you or so
that's that's fine well I calligraffitti
manifesto yeah
yeah all that stuff here that kind of no
we don't we don't yeah we don't know
that's not gonna necessarily help it all
good you know the film will let speak
for itself but
you